the top would be about testability
surprise correlation using Wikipedia now
about myself okay maybe that's not
exactly what I wanted to show you today
yeah that's more like it so I'm a to
data scientist at Knossos we are pin
tech company and we are analyzing
Twitter data for finance I got my PhD
two years ago in natural language
processing and machine learning and I'm
very interested in how these two areas
so unstructured data and finance come
together actually this talk is going to
be about how we can combine or how we
can understand one domain with the aid
of the other more precisely how can use
unstructured data and what is
relationship with traditional financial
data and the reason I am giving this
talk is because there were quite some
questions around okay so there's a lot
of unstructured data but is it actually
useful can we really make use of it
because unstructured data is noisy it
poses a lot of problems let's say that
we have text how can we get from text to
numbers or time series that we actually
know how to model so this talk tries to
explain a little bit what can be done
what what is possible and maybe set some
some future directions okay so as I was
having to financial data traditionally
its time series data so you get your
usual pricing data and you are usually
time series and you are going to make a
prediction based on your past
observations now
in addition to a pricing data and to
other time series that probably some of
you are already looking at there's quite
a lot of unstructured data at people
slowly start to be interested in so it
can be things like annual reports
released by various companies or some
brokers might have a piece of research
that they are publishing you can have
also conference call transcripts you can
have Investor Relations presentations
news press releases and but if you are
Bloomberg probably have sure they have
in-house content now okay but what about
unconventional data sets so I don't know
how many of you are familiar with these
assets like Wikipedia its structure
version dbpedia projects like wiki data
have some of you hard about them or use
them not so much one person yeah yeah
okay oh okay sorry three people 405 okay
good right so then I guess people who
use them of people who've heard them
maybe let's have a smoke what do you
think that there is some potential for
using these data sets in finance one two
three okay well I have lots of
convincing to doing this talk good so
okay because during my PhD I was working
with our structured data and
specifically i was looking at data sets
like wikipedia dbpedia maybe you know of
an ontology that was humanly created
called open side just like and it's it's
an open source version open side then
there's also bubble net so there's
really a lot of projects out there
some of them are created based on people
collaborating and writing about
different topics of interest like
Wikipedia there you have about 10 edits
per second and the english wikipedia
currently has over 5 million articles so
that's an average of eight hundred new
articles per day which is quite
impressive now how can we go from
unstructured data to a more structural
presentation that we can actually make
use of and will hopefully build the
model that's going to predict all the
Holy Grail tomorrow's price so the
structured view views of Wikipedia we
can look at wikipedia in two different
ways at least so one way is to look at
the Wikipedia article itself and this
Wikipedia article can we can build a
vectorized representation out of the
content of the article additionally to
that we can also look at Wikipedia as a
graph so now if we want to build a
representation of the Wikipedia article
an interesting project that was recently
set up is called wiki Tuvok now I guess
most of you know about the word Tuvok
model for those of you who don't know a
lot about it or are not very familiar
with it this model was proposed by
Nicole of it others in back in 2013 and
the the main hypothesis that it was
peeled upon like a lot of other other
models is the distributional hypothesis
which for linguistics is very important
and it basically states that if you have
words in a similar context they are
going to have similar meanings this
model is not really what we would call a
deep learning model it's a shallow
only two layers in the network as you
can see from the image has only one
hidden state and the idea behind it is
that it wants to learn vector
representations which can predict nearby
words which can predict the context okay
so this is very nice but if you want to
compare not words in Wikipedia but we
want to compare wikipedia articles we
need to go a bit further than that so
one idea which is basically wiki to lack
is well we know how to generate vector
actually contact vectors for the way he
peed the words in the Wikipedia articles
but in a similar fashion we can also
create a context vector for the
Wikipedia articles themselves and let's
say that these are topics so that means
that if you have let's say an abstract
from an article saying Unilever is an
anglo-dutch multinational consumer goods
company and Unilever is a link to the
actual Unilever company which represents
a Wikipedia article and additional you
also have the multinational consumer
goods company which is again a link to
some other Wikipedia Wikipedia article
and what he would you would do is you
would assign an ID to each of these
links in your in your text and thereby
you are going to generate vectors not
only for your words but also for article
IDs if you want ok on the other hand we
have the Wikipedia graph so I don't know
how familiar you are with with the
Wikipedia structure but you can
essentially build two types of nodes you
can all you can build nodes which
represent the articles themselves or you
can also build nodes which represent the
categories in Wikipedia and these
categories are
basically labels that are assigned to
each article and that tell you okay so
for example Unilever is part of the
London Stock Exchange so its category
will be London Stock Exchange part of
London Stock Exchange ok so now
established which are the nodes now the
directed edges he'd have several types
of directed edges so you can have what
we've seen before the hyperlinks from
article to article you can have info box
links again from article to article you
can have links from an article to a
category or you can also have links
between these categories so you can
build quite quite size of a graph out of
the entire wikipedia now okay so we have
the graph now washer what are we going
to actually do with this graph well two
things we could do for example so let's
say we do something very simple we we
have our nodes in the graph and we say
okay two nodes are similar if the
distance between them is where they are
they're very close together or we can
also say hey why not apply random walk
algorithms on our graph so we can look
at a page rank and actually more
interesting a version of page and called
personalized page rank which it
basically uses the query to define how
important is the vertex that I am
looking at and it's going to prefer
vertexes which are close to this query
okay so now we know how to represent our
data set how are we going to use these
kind of representations in order to see
if they are useful for any type of
financial task
so okay the analysis that came up was
let's look at the footy 100 index and
let's see what kind of information can I
pull out of that okay so we took the
footy 100 index companies we knew it
sector market capitalisation quite a lot
of information just out of Wikipedia
then we also knew how to compute a
similarity between to Wikipedia articles
which these to Wikipedia articles are
basically the companies that I am
interested in part of the 4100 we use
jency muerto back this allowed us to
build our word to back bottle and the
enhanced version we hit over and also to
compute the similarity between any two
articles so we would obtain a pairwise
similarity something like this so we
would have company or and company too
and it's worth back similarity now there
are several reasons why you're not going
to obtain a similarity for each pair of
two companies the reasons maybe your
article is very short there's not enough
information or you are going when
building your work to let model you are
going to set quite some trash holes in
order to obtain something meaningful
another reason why we are going to have
missing values in our data set on the
other hand we are going to have our
pricing data so this is your usual your
usual time series data set and what we
are going to do the pricing data is that
we are going to obtain our dead returns
for each foot see 100 company and we are
going to also compute a correlation for
if possible there so again like in these
up in the previous example we have
company company too and our correlation
and now
we have two different views we have on
one hand our Wikipedia similarities and
on the other hand we have our
correlations from our pricing data great
so the question is does the Wikipedia
similarity explain correlation of
returns what is your guess and why is
that what is the reason for which it
does you will say yes because otherwise
I wouldn't be here presenting in front
of ya i was asking you i was asking the
audience what is your what is your gut
feeling why is it really that because
there were a few people who said yes
there is some some correlation any idea
why why should there be any correlation
on one hand we have this unstructured
data set has nothing to do with finance
nobody ever came up with the idea of
putting information in there that
actually yeah
yeah we also thought so but then you
would expect that if you would pull a
sector out you are going to have no
correlation whatsoever or you're going
to have only correlation in that
particular sector yeah okay sorry again
how how do i check the dial in the
future psycho fine hmm I I didn't really
think of that how what exactly would you
mean that right yeah yeah we that's an
interesting observation with Pete we
would have served this in a in a very
specific case I'm going to refer to if
you bear with me until the end of the
presentation so okay so there there you
go now this is the results that I'm
going the time showing here are for a
subset of the of the [ __ ] 100 companies
which have a market capitalization
greater than 7 which is a media market
capitalization among the 4100 companies
the reason that we chose this is cause
if we take companies that have lower
market capitalization they do not have
so much content in Wikipedia
additionally to that these companies
they have lots of content that is not
particularly useful in order to
determine how similar they are they are
so for example they will have things
like there is some conflict there is
some change in ownership there is some
a restructuring going on and that is
very very detailed in Wikipedia but
doesn't really help us with determining
the similarity between this particular
company and and another company so yeah
what we found that it's not really the
case that it's this is valid for a
particular sector it's more the case
that it's valid above a certain market
capitalization moreover if we go even
further and look at at an even higher
market capitalization then the r2
becomes quite interesting now let me
come back to the question that we had
previously so before I was telling you
about Grethe graphs and how we can use
them in order to analyze analyze
Wikipedia data now what happens is that
the graph based similarity it does
capture exactly that that you have you
have information about companies in a
single topic with they are part of the
same topic which is all of them are part
of the 4100 so all of them are going to
be labeled with categories that our
company is based in companies that are
part of the longest stock exchange
companies that are part of the footy 100
and that is going to imply that these
companies are going to have a vet they
are going to be very similar based on
the graph measure of similarity however
this is not the case if we are using the
word tyvek model because they're the
context is able to capture much more
information and therefore it allows us
to see this kind of correlation which we
did not see with the graph based measure
so yeah the it is in fact Wikipedia and
unconventional source of unstructured
data has explanatory power for financial
variables the other thing that we saw
was that context by similarity so the
word to black model is powerful
in order to capture information within
the context but aside from that nobody
would have said there is any kind of
information that we can pull out of such
an unstructured source that nobody had
an idea of using it for this particular
purpose so the high pollen is that is
that a lot more can be gained from
industry specific documents so if we are
looking at annual reports on conference
call transcripts there's much more
information there because these data
sets are created specifically with the
purpose of financial analysis now there
are several applications that we can
look at so yeah what are we doing this
why do why is it interesting find such
correlations well one one possible
application is predicting financial
figures solely based on unstructured
data or even thinking of a hybrid model
that combines unstructured and
structured data another possible
application domain estimating financial
figures ratio statistical models other
kind of relevant quantitative data which
is not available and one example is the
time preceding the IPO here are some of
the resources that I've used in the
presentation so for the word too vague
and wiki Tuvok models the graph by
similarity and also I will make the
novels of the presentation available in
case you want to play around with so
thank you and you have any questions
did you did you play for with different
time spans in the correlation of
financial data and which are the better
well that's what so different time
spends um the data that i was showing if
we go back starts 2013 now the thing is
that if we look at let's say start in
2013 even earlier we are going to have
the problem that in that wikipedia
doesn't in wikipedia the information
gets captured in a different way than in
a pricing data so for example what
happens when companies merge you had the
case of demons which sold its entire an
entire part of the industry to a
different company that's that's
something that is very easily reflected
in the price but on the other hand all
these kind of changes are very hard to
track in wikipedia so yeah we did play
with with time and the thing is that you
the more you go back in time the harder
it is to have any kind of relationship
yeah hi in the I was wondering but how
you did similarity between articles
because were to vac you feed him
sentences and then it gives you
associations with context and so
typically for for each word you'll get a
vector which represents it in this new
space in this small space so when you
compare articles there are many words in
an articles and sometime articles are
not the same don't have the same number
of words so from just a vector for four
words how do you compact up to
to compare articles okay so several
observations here were two back is a
collection of algorithms there's the
initial word back what it did is you
have one one single word and for each
word you obtain a vector e presentation
and that vector representation is going
to be fine night so that's why you can
compare two words among each other now
the trick let's say that we apply in
order to obtain the Wikipedia article
comparison was that we were changing in
text the link to an article with an ID
that uniquely identified that particular
article so then if this ID becomes
actually award in text and therefore we
could obtain a similar vector
representation for the word for words of
course and then also for this additional
article represented by the ID and
because we have it in our if you want
key so it is among our keys we can then
retrieve it and compare the that were
articles we could also compare an
article with the word for example so
essentially you reduced articles to like
a bunch of keywords and if the keywords
were similar in a word she like sense
then they were similar in an article to
article sign exactly exactly like that
thank you
thanks for very very interesting talk
first of all and so thinking intuitively
if two companies are similar right
according to a word to whack autograph
then intuitively there could be
nonmonotonic relationships between their
stock prices I seen assuming they're in
the same sector if the sector as a whole
is growing then there will be positive
correlation between the stock prices if
the sector itself is now growing that
much then the two companies are
basically competitors right so in theory
why Rice's other should lose out I did
you consider Latino again this is all
these kind of observations that you can
easily get from price analysis are very
hard to obtain from text unless or at
least you are not going to be able to
obtain it out of Wikipedia this is the
reason why probably hybrid model that
combines the two is going to be more
powerful because in the end they're
complementary data sets you are going to
obtain some information from your prices
but it can very well be that you don't
have this price data available or let's
say that the price data everybody is
using the this price data and
everybody's running their models so
there's very little that you can gain in
comparison to your competitor but then
maybe if you are using unstructured data
whereas your competitor is not using it
there might be something in there that
should not be overlooked did you have a
go yeah are you do you ever go m doing
any kind of quantitative back testing on
this so it looks like statistical
arbitrage effectively if you're able to
track what the movement between the
stocks of different companies is so did
you did you do any any back testing and
would you have made any money I think
this is more like let's try see what
comes out of it idea if the reasonable
answer to the question is there any kind
of relationship between gippi Riya and
stock price data is no there shouldn't
why should there be because Wikipedia I
self cannot explain and again if you go
back and you start looking at your data
since I don't know the 1920s there has
been so much development in there maybe
wikia doesn't even track that
information now to backtest it hmm in
what kind of setting how how would you
back test it well you could look at you
could look at the Wikipedia articles
over the last 10 years and run the model
on older older versions of organizations
wikipedia and work out what you would
have decided to do in track against the
stock price and work out the weather
your statistical our charge would have
worked or not the problem is that the
Wikipedia as it evolves over time
doesn't really evolved in order to
reflect price evolution because it
evolves very organically by people
adding more information but it's just
the similarity between two two
organizations you're interested in if if
they're moving in opposite directions
when your models are they moving in the
same or one has moved because I know
Pepsi results have come out with take
seven it's very hard it's very hard to
get this kind of two companies moving in
different directions or these companies
are competitors these companies working
the same sector out of the EP a-- they
they will be similar if they were if
they under same sector again if they are
competitors share the same sector they
will also be similar because i don't
know they are both higher manufacturers
so there there are certain limits of
what you can explain using this kind of
data set thanks
potentially i think this is just that
there could be the prelude of a
statistical arbitrage strategy cut it
gives you it tells you what the pair's
you should be looking at but then they
yet but then the next step would be okay
at which point does the spread between
those pairs that the model is predicted
is too much out of line for you to say
cell by and so and so on so that's
that's what could be useful if it's
reliable hi thanks for the talk and how
do you combine the two distant magic
that you have so you have one the graph
based distance matrix between two
companies I don't know what is like the
modified talk to vac let's say this
metric when how do you combine them in a
linear combination or you have known
your faction is combining it okay so we
tried we tried using both independently
not combining them the problem with the
graph metric is that it does not really
reflect similarity between companies and
the reason is because these companies
because I'm looking and I'm focusing on
this particular domain all of them are
going to be highly interning especially
because of the categories these
categories are extremely high level so
as I said the examples are all companies
listed on the london stock exchange well
surprise all of them are our companies
built in the in the food c180 so because
of this i'm going to obtain for all my
company's high similarity measures and
this is not going to help me to
distinguish I don't know if I have a
pair Tesco and Sainsbury's which are
similar versus Tesco and I don't know 3i
which are probably have very little in
common so in the end the analysis was
done on word Tuvok which turned out to
be much more powerful in getting exactly
this kind of information out based on
the context an interesting question
would be why isn't the graph measure
capable of exerting because usually
these graph measures they
very the people are very good results
using rough measures for tasks like or
sense disambiguation where you have
words from different topics and then see
okay is this word that is reflect opik a
or talking now because I'm narrowing
down it seems that the same algorithms
that work in a particular domain don't
work so well in this particular example
but we haven't really dug into why and
how to adapt this metric in order to be
able to capture similarity within that
same okay they are no more questions
thank you very much to dr. DNA research